tea is in chicago
starting off the hour hi tay how are you
hi how are you better than i deserve
what's up
okay so monsters your brother are
homeless we left my mother's house
because she was mentally and mentally um
mentally abusive and also financially
irresponsible so my mother left my mom's
house and moved in with my
my friends in their basement and then
literally not even like three weeks
after that i lost my job
and i got a new one right after i'm at
that one currently i've been there for
like
like two or three weeks now but i hate
it i hate it bad i really cannot stand
it
at all whatsoever you don't like your
job
hey tay before you keep going can you
tell us how you really feel about your
job
what do you hate about it tay i mean
you've only been there long enough to
really hate it i mean
what is what's the what's the problem
what's the problem
they only get with one week of training
yeah um to learn
them but but then they give us any
training on the actual
questions that people are going to ask
us so they tell us to call a helpline
to get help to answer the question but
then the helpline doesn't know the
answer to the question
and then there's the answer to the
question is also not so what do you do
what do you do all day because you don't
know the answer the question the
helpline doesn't know they answer the
question you can't answer the question
what do you do
what do you do with your day you just
tell people i don't know the answer all
day
obviously basically i'm going to manage
it for you because
this is a little confusing i'm going to
transfer you that's all i do
for eight hours okay so how much do you
make
um this job here is two thousand about
two thousand like
two thousand a month okay so go get
another job
that's the plan but the issue is i'm
trying to get
i'm trying to i'm trying to we're
homeless i'm trying to get out of my
friend's house
yeah i didn't tell you to quit the job i
said go get another job
then quit the job okay
yeah you're living in your friend's
basement you don't have a lot of luxury
right now you don't have a lot of wiggle
room you're gonna have to do some really
uncomfortable things
and stick it out and if the worst part
of this transition is that you're in a
job that's annoying and they're not
training you very much but it's inside
and there's a heater
and you gotta and they give you money
yeah they're paying you
i would i would ride that out and find
something that's gonna pay you more
money that's gonna
be better fit for you as soon as you go
find a job making three thousand dollars
as soon as you do quit the dumb job okay
but don't quit the dumb job when you're
living in somebody's basement you have
no money
okay you don't have that luxury
unless there's something you haven't
told me like you have a hundred thousand
dollars in your bank account or
something
i wish i had 1000
feel free to go get another job of
course um but don't quit that job until
you've got another
don't what do they say feel free to go
get three more jobs right
if you're at somebody so you're never
this broke again you've got an emergency
that's right
how many hours a week are you working
now
40 and then also um i also have my um i
do have a
second job i work for a jewelry store as
well um but
they followed me and they just brought
me back so only work 13 hours on the
weekends
for that's not enough it's only 53 hours
you need to be working 80 hours
you're broken in somebody's basement
work more go get a different job dump
the dumb job and get your financial plan
going
listen here's the deal pretend with me
for a second you made five thousand
dollars a month
how much different would your life feel
oh that's what i'm prescribing for you
it's not that money is the answer to
everything but when you have no money
money is the answer to almost everything
it's like you know i mean it's not it's
not a spiritual thing
it's a matter of you freaking you're
right on the edge of homelessness
right and so you've got to pile up some
cash and the only way money the only
place money comes from is work
right so you need to be like you re i'm
being real serious you need to have no
freaking life
you don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant your friends are going out
for drinks toughies unless you're
serving them from behind the bar
i mean you are not doing squat except
working and making money because you
have no money and you need some
it is that primitive a formula right
you got to get you got to get going and
you've got to look at your situation and
and
think i'm in a basement you know they're
not training me well that's not a thing
right now
right you are running it's like a
gazelle running through the woods right
and being like
this terrain is really uncomfortable
we're gonna need to go over there and
run in that grass you know what you just
gotta run you gotta run you gotta run
you gotta run yeah because there's a
cheetah on your butt that's right
yeah and you don't get the luxury of
where you're running that's right you
just run
go that's the deal that's it good for
you
and here's the thing stick it out that's
right stick it out until
and then tell them take this job and
shove it when you get the other one i'm
fine with that that
ain't any issue with you changing i do
have an issue with you quitting
there's a difference because you don't
have that mathematical
option kit